gibt es schon längst einen kontakt zu
aliens und wir wissen es nur noch nicht
einiges spricht dafür dass außerirdische
und zumindestens beobachten ein halion
satellit im erdorbit gilt als
wahrscheinlichstes szenario jedenfalls
wenn man nach dem kanadier alan traf
gehen und der deutsche kultur soziologe
michael schätzle hält sogar eine erste
kontaktaufnahme für möglich und zwar
eine die bereits stattgefunden hat die
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
es gibt bekanntes bekannteste dinge von
denen wir wissen dass wir wissen wir
wissen auch dass es bekannte unbekannte
gibt das heißt wir wissen es gibt dinge
die wir nicht wissen aber es gibt auch
unbekannte unbekannte dinge also von
denen wir nicht wissen dass sie nicht
wissen
diese denkwürdige anmerkung stammt vom
ehemaligen amerikanischen
verteidigungsminister donald rumsfeld
und er hat nicht so ganz unrecht und
gerade beim thema aliens gibt es eine
menge dass wir nicht wissen und
wissenschaftler sind sich sicher dass
wir vieles nicht wissen und auch nicht
wissen dass wir es nicht wissen
allerdings kann man das ändern und das
unwissen über das was wir nicht wissen
etwas verringert denn es ist eben nicht
so dafür über den ersten kontakt mit
aliens rein gar nicht wissen wenn wir
ein paar grundannahmen durchdenken dann
wissen wir sogar eine menge darunter der
ansatz von michael schätzle ist dabei
sehr interessant dem kultursoziologe er
hat nämlich einige rahmenbedingungen zum
erstkontakt durchdacht die hellhörig
machen er geht davon aus dass art und
ort des kontaktes die kollektiven
psychischen projektionen auf die aliens
aber wenn wir zum beispiel für böse
halten weil wir hässlich sind und die
möglichkeit der geheimhaltung
entscheidend für die folgen eines
erstkontakte sind und die folgen können
dramatisch sein dass absolute horror
szenario wäre ihm nach eine erste
begegnung hier auf der erde mit alien
von denen wir uns bedroht fühlen es
wurde sofort zur weltweiten massenpanik
kommen und das vollkommen unabhängig von
den absichten der außerirdischen in der
folge würde sich bei entsprechender
technischer und kultureller
überlegenheit ein verhältnis von
entdecker und entdeckten bilden die zur
kompletten zerstörung unserer kultur und
wissenschaft führen würde
wir wären unmündige unwissenden
elefanten die von der überlegenen spät
ist an die hand genau
werden würden und das geschieht ganz
unabhängig davon ob die außerirdischen
uns unterwerfen wollen oder nicht die
konsequenzen wären sie uns in jedem fall
absolut dramatisch zetsche wünscht sich
der biber keinen kontakt oder zumindest
ein über weite distanzen oder an einem
neutralen ort aber in jedem fall nicht
auf der erde deshalb geht aber auch
davon aus dass wenn es ihn gegeben haben
sollte er tatsächlich von dem jeweiligen
land geheim gehalten wurde weil die
folge neben unabsehbar wären zwar sei er
kein anhänger von verschwörungstheorien
aber wenn eine gemeinschaft wie zum
beispiel beim bau der atombombe vom
nutzen der geheimhaltung überzeugt ist
dann könnte ein solches wissen auch über
jahre verborgen werden bei der atombombe
hat es trotz tausender mitwisser
geklappt allerdings müssen eben alle
mitglieder dieser gemeinschaft vom
positiven nutzen überzeugt sein jetzt
noch mal zurück zu allen taft er hat ein
team von psychologen um sich geschart
und sogar eine einladung an aliens im
netz veröffentlicht allerdings hat er
die antwort nicht mehr erlebte er 2012
gestorben und ehrlich gesagt war auch
pädagoge hat aber nicht den optimalen
wissenschaftlichen bäckern aber er hatte
eigentlich eine ganz vernünftige idee
wenn es außerirdisches leben im weltall
gibt dann muss es zivilisationen geben
die unsere haushoch überlegen sind der
grund unsere erde ist etwa 4 6
milliarden jahre als das universum ist
aber exakt dreimal so alt mit 13,8
milliarden jahren es muss also viel
ältere gewohnte planeten geben mit
dementsprechend weiter entwickelten
zivilisation
jetzt gibt es eigentlich nur ein paar
mögliche szenarien warum wir keinen
kontakt zu ihnen haben erstens es gibt
zu viele spezies im universum wirbeln
ziemlich uninteressant sie haben einfach
kein interesse an uns zweitens sie
beobachten uns bereit und haben einen
satelliten in der erdumlaufbahn oder
irgendwo im system ein objekt das so
klein ist dass wir es einfach nicht
entdecken
drittens der kontakt hat bereits
stattgefunden und wird aber geheim
gehalten weil die von michael schätzle
geschilderten gefahren drohen oder last
but not least viertens es ist wie beim
raumschiff enterprise wenn wir den warp
antrieb erfunden haben nehmen die
außerirdischen kontakt mit uns auf weil
wir sie dann auch probleme
erreichen können wir wissen also eine
ganze menge über den erstkontakt nur
nicht welche der varianten tatsächlich
wirklichkeit wird
oder ist ja sobald es neue erkenntnisse
gibt werden ist natürlich hier erfahren
sollte mir dafür hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesse ich den glocken nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter mit den gefahren die davon
ausgehen wenn wir aliens und wichtig zu
uns locken oder bereits gelockt haben
davor warnt michael schätzle nämlich und
da haben wir dann schon eine menge mist
gebaut und welchen dass sie dem video
und ansonsten bestand bleibt dran